Traduttore: Federico Pepe
Revisore: Łukasz Luke
Salve.
Siamo degli storyteller
e amiamo raccontare storie,
e amiamo ascoltarle.
Non c'è platea migliore del TED
e del TEDx per ascoltare
storie che ci ispirano,
che ci uniscono,
che ci emozionano.
Per Mario ho i calzini
di "Fight the Stroke"
perché la sua storia, come tante altre,
mi ha emozionato tantissimo.
Come storyteller noi abbiamo
iniziato a illustrare le nostre storie
da tanto tempo fa, le abbiamo
illustrate sui muri delle caverne
e le abbiamo ascoltate
di fianco al fuoco,
le abbiamo portate nelle piazze,
le abbiamo cantate nei teatri
che abbiamo qua vicino e le abbiamo
scritte con linguaggi nuovi
e parole misteriose.
Abbiamo offerto la
possibilità agli artisti,
agli scienziati, agli scrittori
di collaborare insieme,
di scoprire incredibili nuovi modi
per emozionarci.
Circa 125 anni fa abbiamo iniziato a
illustrare le nostre storie
sulla pellicola, e gli storyteller
dell'inizio del '900
hanno dovuto inventarsi dei nuovi
linguaggi visivi,
qualcosa che non c'era prima,
hanno dovuto giocare con la luce
e con le ombre, con i colori
e con il bianco e nero,
con i suoni, che non potevano
neanche mettere sulla pellicola,
e con i silenzi.
Hanno dovuto scoprire, pionieri come
i fratelli Lumière, Méliès,
Griffith e Porter, scoprire
la potenza e l'importanza
del montaggio cinematografico, dei tempi,
delle dissolvenze, di una pausa,
del movimento di camera.
Un semplice tratto di matita
diventava una principessa.
Artisti visionari hanno scoperto che se
mettevano in sequenza migliaia di disegni
creavano l'illusione
di un'incredibile danza.
Gli effetti speciali,
i primi effetti speciali,
ci hanno portato in mondi fantastici.
Ci hanno fatto spaventare da
mostri che non esistevano,
e ci hanno fatto combattere
di fianco ai supereroi,
e poi il computer è arrivato e ha reso
questi mondi ancora più fantastici,
ha reso i mostri ancora più spaventosi
e i supereroi ancora più forti.
E abbiamo fatto tutto questo
per emozionarci,
per poterci raccontare storie
sempre più incredibili,
e in tutto questo, creare delle immagini
che sarebbero rimaste con noi
anche quando uscivamo dal cinema.
E io sono cresciuto a cinema
e a cartoni animati, a fantascienza e tv,
come spettatore, sognando
di diventare uno storyteller.
Abbiamo anche scoperto che se
indossiamo dei miracolosi occhialini
tutto il mondo di fronte a noi
diventa a tre dimensioni
e lo schermo è passato dal piccolo muro
del caffè di Parigi agli schermi IMAX
delle ultime generazioni.
Circa 40 anni fa, mio padre
mi ha regalato questa camera,
e un giorno magico ho scoperto
che se premevo il pulsante verso l'alto
non giravo un film: scattavo
un singolo fotogramma,
uno dei 24 che compongono
un secondo di film.
Da quel magico giorno, tutto il mio mondo
è cambiato: pennarelli, carte colorate,
pongo, LEGO, qualsiasi cosa
erano diventati i soggetti
dei miei cartoni animati,
delle mie storie.
Non ero più uno spettatore,
ero diventato un creatore
ed ero diventato un storyteller.
Un paio di anni dopo, mio
padre mi regala questo
e i miei disegni diventano digitali,
e tutta la mia vita si incanala in un
paciugo di arte e tecnologia...
- voglio vedere come traducono "paciugo" -
it's mashup.
Inizia questa avventura digitale
e artistica per oltre 30 anni.
Ho iniziato a fare le prime immagini
digitali a pochi metri da qui,
ed erano le sigle dei telegiornali
di Verona e dei goffi personaggi,
abbastanza semplici,
e poi 20 anni fa ho deciso
di attraversare l'oceano
e di arrivare in California
per seguire un sogno
e sognare insieme a decine
di altri artisti e tecnici che, come me,
volevano scoprire le emozioni
nelle immagini fredde del computer,
negli 0 e negli 1.
Ci siamo sentiti dei pionieri, all'inizio,
perché dovevamo scoprire
dietro una linea di codice,
dietro il colore di un pixel
l'emozione di poter raccontare
e di esplorare un nuovo linguaggio visivo.
Ho speso 17 anni con queste persone,
500 circa di loro, e con loro
abbiamo realizzato tanti film,
da "Z la formica", "Shrek", "Madagascar"
"Dragons" e tanti tanti altri...
Persone che hanno diviso ogni giorno
e ogni notte con me a inventare
e a spingere i limiti di questo
nuovo storytelling,
sia dal punto di vista tecnico
che dal punto di vista creativo.
Abbiamo fatto tesoro di quello
che c'era stato raccontato
dagli storyteller precedenti,
e abbiamo cercato con i creativi
e con i registi di spingere
questo linguaggio sempre di più.
Mi sono ritrovato in tutti questi anni
a essere di nuovo un creatore;
a essere emozionato
per poter emozionare.
La cosa strana è che per
20 anni abbiamo fatto film
nel mezzo della Silicon Valley.
E tutto intorno a noi -
vivevamo in questo fantastico
castello colorato immaginario -
e tutto intorno a noi cambiava:
quando sono arrivato non c'era Facebook,
non c'era Google, che è nata 3 anni dopo,
non c'era Instagram, non c'era Twitter,
Netflix, non c'era l'iPhone,
non c'era l'iPad, non
c'era niente di tutto questo.
E in tutti questi anni, mentre noi
facevamo film e raccontavamo
ed evolvevamo questo linguaggio, il
mondo, e il modo in cui il mondo parlava,
discuteva, scopriva le notizie, le storie,
si raccontava le storie, le consumava,
stava cambiando.
Questo è mio figlio e mi
porterà in tribunale per questo...
(Risate)
Il modo in cui le nuove generazioni
interagiscono con la tecnologia
ci ha sempre stupefatto e spaventato
allo stesso tempo:
l'ho vissuto con Noah e con
Emily sulla nostra pelle.
Loro non vivono con la televisione
che ha fatto da babysitter a me,
loro vivono di streaming: non abbiamo
la tv da 8 anni in casa nostra,
e abbiamo solo streaming
su qualsiasi device.
E loro vivono di immediatezza, di scelte
infinite, storie vecchie e storie nuove.
Noah, e la sua generazione, non toccherà
mai una tastiera o un mouse:
vivrà di tocco e di interazione
con le storie create
e i mondi virtuali creati dagli adulti.
Questo ci ha guidato, tre anni fa,
a lasciare tutto, a lasciare
l'esperienza con Dreamworks
e di fondare una società con Nadia
e con Erwan che si chiama "Curious Hat".
L'idea fondamentale che ci ha
guidato è quella di offrire,
attraverso le nuove tecnologie,
un modo per le nuove generazioni
di interagire con il mondo reale.
Noi crediamo fortemente che
le nuove generazioni possano creare
dei bellissimi mondi virtuali solo
se sono a conoscenza della bellezza
e dell'importanza del mondo reale.
Abbiamo creato delle app che univano
e che portavano i bambini a interagire
con il mondo reale,
attraverso tutte le funzionalità
che questi nuovi device offrivano.
Per tre anni abbiamo vissuto
un'incredibile, esilarante
ed estremamente stressante
vita da startuppari.
Tutto intorno il mondo cambiava
ancora: lo storytelling e il cinema
hanno incontrato il mobile e circa un
quarto della popolazione del mondo
adesso ha uno smartphone, e nel 2014
i guadagni delle app hanno
superato quelli di Hollywood.
Dal 1888 al 2014, e sono gli anni
dal kinetoscopio ai Google Cardboard,
abbiamo fatto un incredibile percorso
e corsa per scoprire nuovi linguaggi.
Lo storytelling e il cinema
hanno un'opportunità, adesso,
con il mobile e con la realtà virtuale
di raccontare nuove storie.
Noi possiamo consumare contenuti
dovunque siamo, ovunque siamo
e lo storyteller sa dove lo spettatore è,
cosa sta facendo, cosa sta provando.
E la storia può modificarsi
di conseguenza.
Il rapporto, il contratto che c'è tra lo
storyteller e lo spettatore è cambiato.
Il posto tra lo spettatore
e l'attore si è invertito.
Lo spettatore sul mobile,
su queste storie interattive,
è al centro della scena e gli attori
stanno tutti intorno a recitare.
Circa 4 mesi fa ho iniziato a lavorare
per un gruppo speciale in Google
che si chiama "Spotlight Stories",
dove investighiamo
queste nuove tecnologie:
come possiamo raccontare
nuove storie sul mobile,
storie interattive?
Glen Keane, che è il più
grande disegnatore che noi abbiamo,
ha disegnato per "Spotlight Stories"
una storia che si chiama Duet.
Glen Keane ha disegnato "Tarzan",
"La Sirenetta", la "Bella e la Bestia",
"Aladdin", è incredibile
vederlo disegnare.
Per "Spotlight Stories" ha creato Duet
che è la storia della vita intrecciata,
semplice ed emozionante,
di un bambino e di una bambina.
Volevo farvelo vedere, prima,
nel formato più tradizionale,
quello che voi vedreste al cinema.
(Applausi)
Ma la cosa bella è che Duet non è nato
per essere visto così,
è nato per essere visto
su un dispositivo mobile.
E anche se abbiamo dei problemi tecnici,
cercherò con l'aiuto di questa buon'anima
di farvi vedere che cos'è
veramente l'esperienza.
Dovunque io guardo il film si sposta
e il mondo sta tutto intorno a me
e la storia sta tutta intorno a me.
In questo momento i due bambini
stanno nascendo,
di fronta la scena è fissa; ma io posso
iniziare a muovermi un pochino...
ho iniziato dalla parte sbagliata...
A questo punto entrano in scena
tutti e due: io sto guardando il film
di fronte a me e mi si è rimosso
un velo, che è quello del cinema,
e adesso posso tornare a vedere
la bambina che sta qui.
Il bambino sta continuando
qui la sua storia
e io non la vedo, adesso,
ma la potrò vedere dopo
se ricomincio a guardare,
o se mi sposto.
Incomincio questa stranissima danza,
questo rapporto con il film,
con la storia, con i personaggi
che il regista ha potuto fare
e non potrebbe fare al cinema.
Potrei seguire il bambino, e scoprire
che ama rotolarsi e scalare.
Se mi perdo, c'è una piccola farfalla
che mi riporta in mezzo, nella scena.
Loro sono qui, come avete visto
prima; ma io posso muovermi,
e il suono è tutto 3D e incredibilmente
bello da ascoltare,
c'è uno Stradivari che suona...
(Applausi)
Loro si incontrano,
alla fine si baciano sempre
(Risate)
era chiaro, ma anzi nessuno
dei ragazzi dello studio sapeva
se si baciavano o no fino alla fine
e Glen, mi raccontano,
ha deciso all'ultimo momento
di disegnare il bacio.
La cosa che mi emoziona è questo
rinascimento dello storytelling
che abbiamo.
Ho lavorato a tantissimi film
e adesso mi ritrovo con un mezzo,
con un medium nuovo, con strumenti
che non esistono ancora,
con linguaggi che non
conosciamo ancora tutti,
e c'è tantissimo da sognare
e da realizzare.
È un altro muro da oltrepassare.
Grazie.
(Applausi)